el líbano ya tiene un nuevo parlamento y
por primera vez las fuerzas de la
oposición están representadas con el 10%
de los escaños la entrada de diputados
independientes es el resultado del
descontento de los libaneses por la
profunda crisis económica que atraviesa
el país que ha llevado a más del 80% de
la población libanesa a vivir bajo el
umbral de la pobreza el gran perdedor de
estas elecciones ha sido el movimiento
patriótico libre del presidente michelle
a un aliado cristiano de hezbollah
frente a las fuerzas libanesas de samir
ya ya también cristiano alineado con
occidente y arabia saudí esto significa
que en la próxima carrera presidencial
que tendrá lugar en el mes de octubre ya
ya contaría con un gran apoyo en el
parlamento para ser elegido el próximo
jefe de estado ya que el presidente
tiene que ser un cristiano maronita en
cuanto al bloque traerán y hezbollah que
lo lidera ha perdido algunos sitios que
los han ganado los independientes
hezbollah deja de ser la primera fuerza
en el parlamento y ahora la balanza de
poder se inclina hacia los pro saudíes
el siguiente reto será elegir un nuevo
primer ministro para formar gobierno una
tarea muy difícil aquí en el líbano